there's a lot of life updates a lot of
music updates so i do want to just get
right into it
let's start with a new single with res
it's called taste of you
i listened to it so many times on repeat
because i thought it was so
fun it was very sexy why was this track
that you wanted to be part of
honestly res sent me an early version of
taste of you
and i was so shocked i was like what
why you know cause i know who i am but i
also know like what the general public
thinks i am and i was like
i can't believe that you heard this and
you you thought of me it's just so
something that i would listen to i feel
like it's a little like nine inch nails
res and i have a lot of common taste and
crossover
which is what makes me laugh when people
are like what an unlikely pairing is
we're actually just unbelievably similar
i love the lyrics i love how sexy and
dark it is so i was really excited when
she asked me that
she has my video is coming out i think
in a couple weeks
very soon what can you tease there's
definitely
going to be a reason that you're gonna
wanna watch till the end it's really
sexy
rez is not usually in her videos so that
was really fun for both of us
you know it's like classic horror movie
trope stuff
but with some steaminess mixed in i feel
like the song is such a good follow-up
to lazy baby which is so good
and i know that you also wrote on that i
feel like that song is kind of your baby
right now
what really inspired that song the
lyrics are very
candid specific obviously lazy baby is
about a breakup
i went through a very public breakup
last year and i
was in a really bad place like a really
really
bad place that i didn't know or after
the breakup
oh after the breakup yeah the breakup me
up
is what people want to know it was
really hard i needed something that was
going to get me from
where i was in the morning process onto
into the other side
and i didn't quite know how i was going
to do that i was alone and it was
during the pandemic no one could come
out and see me and i couldn't leave
canada
so i was really struggling to work
through that and lazy baby was this like
kind of satirical comedic
uplifting you know i i do best when i
can laugh at my pain
it really helped me get from one place
to the next with the breakup and also
thomas loves it he listens to it all the
time i sent it to him before it came out
and he said he still sends me voice
notes all the time being like
right there so yeah everything's very
amicable but i was gonna say so you guys
are in a good place and i actually
wasn't gonna get too much into the
thomas of it all
because i wanted to respect the privacy
but i have talked to you a lot about him
i've talked to him about you
a lot and if you want to say anything
about like what happened i think it's
nice to hear that things are amicable
i guess i will give you that opportunity
i don't think i'll ever
probably go into what happened i think
that we both feel
that that's something that is just
between us but we love each other so
much it's like i always say like
i personally believe we have many soul
mates in this life but i don't think
that somebody stops being a soul mate
when
you break up like i will love him
differently now
it's different now before anybody runs
away with this but
i think if you love somebody that deeply
you're always gonna love them that
deeply sure you know he's one of my
favorite people in the world and
i don't think we could ever be not in a
good place like even when we were
breaking up we were like i love you so
much
so yeah but anyway yeah it's uh very
mature
and i think that's awesome what did you
learn from that relationship
a lot of things one of my favorite
quotes is the way to know life is to
love many things
and you have to love people with you
know every inch of you and you can't
regret it when it ends and i probably
wouldn't
publicly say that i'm still kind of like
processing and deciding how i feel about
but um
love is very important i'm a huge
romantic i'm very intentionally like
not doing that right now like i need to
learn how to
really explore my life on my own and i
knew that from a very young age and we
met so young thomas and i
i would be remiss if i didn't take this
opportunity to not be in a relationship
so i guess if anything i've just learned
i just i've fallen more in love with
myself
time for some solo dovetime oh yeah
definitely i think everybody needs that
also i think that we romanticize romance
so much
even when i have been in a relationship
i've thought this
that like i think that i think that
every especially young women really need
to
learn to be on their own and like live
alone have their own space
you know like get in their own energy
and find out who you are
not in relationship to someone else
right because that was something that i
i didn't know
let's talk a little bit more about the
music because you have put out a few
songs
since we've last talked since we've been
in this pandemic are you working on
a full-length album right now like
what's going on i'm always working on
music
that could eventually be a full-length
album but i'm definitely working on a
lot of music right now
and but it's just amazing because it's
like i've been much more in the acting
world for the first portion of my career
and so i suddenly find myself surrounded
by
who i respect so much and and we get to
create together and like
what's better than that how has music
helped you over the
course of the past year the past few
months
and what has been inspiring all the new
music that you are working on
you're so good music has been everything
to me but music's always everything to
me
my best mode of medication is music it's
everything and what's been inspiring me
lately
loads of new people oh you know
the changing yeah it's i have a bunch of
new people in my life all of a sudden
which is not
normal for me i have like my best friend
from high school
and then i have the person i was in a
long-term committed relationship with
and then my family but all of a sudden i
have like
these unbelievable kismet new people
where i'm like where
did you come from it's mental it's
amazing i just think that when you are
so alive
music is so easy it flows out of you
you know it's like you don't have to try
because there truly is
too much to write about so much so that
you can't write it down fast enough so
loads of new people in my life very
[Music]
inspiring